the 97 year old Duke of Edinburgh
flipped his car on a busy Norfolk Road
last week an reignited the debate on the
age limit for older drivers a debate
which has spawned insulting presumptions
that everyone over 75 is Gaga and not
fit to dress themselves let alone drive
a car that's not really a gist it's
wrong all the drivers are no more
dangerous than most younger ones in fact
17 to 21 year old men are up to four
times more likely to have an accident
than 70 year olds people talk glibly
about taking licenses away from the
elderly like it's nothing not
understanding that for many driving is
their lifeline
it's about way more than just getting
from A to B it represents their freedom
and independence and not having to ask
for help or permission to do anything
not being able to drive leaves many old
people prisoners in their own homes
isolated and at risk of depression and
loss of mobility yes there should be
rigorous testing and yes certain medical
conditions should preclude driving but
we need to think long and hard before
stealing the independence of millions
just because of a number on their birth
certificate Carol I'm in the
uncomfortable position of basically
agree Wow I first of all I'm horrified
by any suggestion that we should just
strip people of their licenses because
of their age that is a really
destructive and Aegeus idea and I think
it would be like you said really
damaging for people's independence and
also I think it's important to point out
that people under 20 have more fatal
accidents than people over 75 however
there is concern about accidents among
older people especially among older
people quite a lot of people over 75 or
80 for example have stopped driving of
their own volition because they are
concerned about its safety I know what
it's like to not be able to drive
because my mother has very bad eyesight
and she had to stop driving when I was a
child and it was really debilitating for
all of us you know and really impacted
her independence so I think this is
absolutely a subject we should take
seriously and not take too lightly and
but it is worrying when there are any
concerns about roads they
and for under 21 year olds who can be
reckless drivers and people who are
older who maybe do need to be retested I
think we do need to think about how
could we create a regime that's not too
intrusive that's not unreasonable but
they'll also make sure that people who
can't drive safely for whatever reason
and it could be at an age it could it be
could be like my mother because of an
eye condition when they're younger it
could because someone like me doesn't
drive very often and hasn't had a
driving lesson in decades actually quite
outdated so thankfully I dodged the
bullet of having to drive for the
program this week but you know there was
this this report that came out to
Swansea University that said a lot of
the accidents that the elderly have is
because people like us younger people we
hustle them on the road and and I bet
you would all admit to having done this
a summer you say someone over there
they're driving much more slowly much
more carefully than we are and and we
take unnecessary risks to get past let's
put this to bed throw away old and young
people that's all the things considered
we don't have a driving competition
no news anybody old out there yes honest
- is Mark Newman I'm a retired police
advanced driver and I currently run my
own business is driving professional
good morning you understand what we're
gonna be doing it's not well a bit like
your driving test we're gonna be driving
down the road here just regular drive at
the end but we're gonna do an emergency
stop I'll tell you when we're going to
stop which when you stop the car under
control we can do a three-point turn
come back in this direction and then a
parallel park that's just pulling up
against the curb without gauging your
alloy wheels or your tires
yes
stop
I think we both need the loo again
right here I'm going off a bit now all
I've done what they do now
[Music]
come on stop
[Music]
stop
[Music]
it's okay how do you think that when I
thought I was watching him and I knew he
was better and that's a factor than that
he's driven thanks for goodness sake but
I'm drunk so I walk to war and what
what's the hijack thing you've driven on
this myself I do believe that a certain
stage and if anybody feels they get into
that stage you should be tested
medically as well because my next-door
neighbor actually she got to the age
about 80 and she had a heart attack be
on the wheel and piled in now she didn't
thankfully hit anybody she thought I'd
herself but she could have killed
somebody all the research says that that
older people regulate themselves they
don't drive at night they don't drive in
bad conditions mattered I just think I
take your point and of course you know
the statistics demonstrate younger
drivers younger male drivers especially
are more reckless but for that they are
stopped more often by the police and
their insurance is higher so there is a
counterbalance to that but I just worry
that sometimes perhaps strangely Carol
here perhaps you're being a bit too
politically correct you know it's quite
I think obvious that the older you get
the slower your faculties respond to
things so a 97 year old behind the wheel
which is the you know recent example
yeah that's not the normal Philip yeah
and you just think okay 97 there must be
something in the system that slows down
that stage now I'm not saying take their
licenses away I am suggesting that
perhaps there is a case for regular
testing that's all they can take you
have the old plane maybe to have an old
please do slow down that
you know you won't find elder people
texting when they're driving you won't
find older people making phone calls and
like I said before they self-regulate
and if you'd ever watch that program 100
year old drivers because I think there's
more than a hundred of them in the
country currently most of them passed
the test with flying colors because
they're much more careful RTP can I just
before Nick wants coming back to you how
many there are actually mention the
figures if we have a look at this there
are 100 thousand two hundred eighty-one
over 90 is holding a valid driving
license in this country that's according
to the DVLA does that make you feel
uncomfortable Nick well I'll tell you
what makes me feel uncomfortable and
I've got a confession to make I've got
to stop driving to Sky News to record
this program getting up behind great
dyke sounding go we've got is this going
to be a great problem because we're all
many of us are living longer so the
problem that we see now is gonna and
it's fantastic the medicine drugs point
because by 2040 thirteen point four
percent of the population is projected
to be over the age of 75 so let's
combine two strands I think you're
absolutely right I wouldn't want to live
in a country where you are just routine
your licence is taken away and I don't
think any of us would do that but but
imagine I hear what you're saying as
well and I don't like the way as I
understand it and I've looked at the
notes here you effectively
self-certified don't you say yes okay I
think we need to move to a different
situation I think we moved to a position
where and I'm just going to pluck an age
out that let's say 75 we can debate that
where and it's not a full medical and
it's not a full driving test or even the
guy the things you've just done with
that with the met load but it you have
to have an eye test I understand they're
gay parents love an eye test the weekend
after that accident no the police in his
past and this already happens but I
think it has to be done by done you just
need some insight you now have to do you
not have to renew your license every
three years I guess that's true but I
worry about that you know we live in a
society now which has no money for
social care you take the ability to
drive from someone away who still can
drive
and and and you isolate them in there we
have to be I'm not suggesting camicazi
older drama should be allowed to contest
sadly the decision has to be done of
course you know what I heard lots of
people her be seen this week actually
your radio station saying children of
older parents saying we reported our
parents to the DVLA now to me that is
just a wish my son Prince Phillip
driving without his seatbelt honey we've
got a photo of it yeah um
that was two days after the crash good
and you know there if I was his kid I
would say he's no tighten those it looks
like you didn't learn his lesson now
obviously that the other thing is
there's a noisy seven-year-old all right
one wonders whether you just forgot you
know and so I think Nick's point there
about testing you know the intention
shouldn't be to take their licenses away
but if they do fail you know eyesight
tests or breathing tests or if their
heart rates a bit erratic then maybe a
doctor should say to them look you know
what all I'm saying is Prince Phillip
you can afford a driver all I'm saying
if you have to think long and hard
before we do it because if it can end
the lives and the independence of a
safety also should come first
absolutely absolutely